but let's do an unhelpful advice sure so
we have emails we'll answer and then
we'll get out of here
unhelpful advice with bobby delilah and
rick take her shoes off podcast glassman
that's really you doing it live
yeah um would you guys like to decipher
a dream
uh industry question or marriage health
um
no no no it's just a therapy so let's
just do a [ __ ] dream let's just do
dream interpretation
and what do we each do it three
different ones whatever you want to say
i think that we can come together
it's one thing and whatever you want to
say yeah okay this is from a friend of
ours uh a fan of ours hey guys my name
is renee meza i'm a truck driver from
colton california
and i love all you guys and make my and
they make my trips more enjoyable
so thank you renee so i had this dream
that i walked out of my bedroom
to my living room and i saw a bunch of
[ __ ] puddles all over my living room
floor
i turned to my left and i see bobby
crouching on top of my couch giggling
and saying
and he was just wearing some american
flag underwear patriotic
i turn to my right i see bobby's parents
cleaning up the puddles and his dad was
yelling at me saying
why did i let him do this and who was
that wait and whose dad was yelling
uh bobby's dad my own dad was yelling at
bobby no was yelling at
the this guy renee renee saying renee
why did you let bobby do that come on
the floor
p.s uh he wants to know what does this
mean
and he'd like to give a shout out to his
wife uh maria i love you
i'll see you soon cause he's a truck
driver yeah that is really sweet
okay um take a stab first well i mean uh
i i can't i you know i don't have enough
variables
and i have a couple of questions because
clearly there's
this renee is reaching out to this
podcast with the dream he had so i
wonder how
manufactured this is uh but
what i need to know his relationship
with his parents
to know this and his relationship with
his wife
but off the top of my head i just think
he's a fan of bobby and dreamed about
him and he's just
that's he's like he's a blue writer
so i can't really give you any wow wow
is there a piece the fact that uh
bobby's dad did not yell at bobby but
yelled at renee
i mean there's so many factors there's
bobby's relationship with your father
and everything that has happened that he
might be projecting
there's is he connecting with that or is
he assuming something on him
what's his that's why i want to know his
relationship with his rights bobby
that was a test i wrote that email
oh well then i i could i i have an
answer for you
go ahead um i without revealing too much
uh it would be fair to assume you guys
have at least opened the conversation
of wanting to start a family mm-hmm and
with that
who who might who am i comes its
challenges
you have a new it's challenging you have
it's
you have a new home and not just in the
physical space but in a
in a in a world that has changed
and things need to be clean and things
need to be organized you want to be this
you're this beta who wants to be this
dominant force you have found someone
who
let you let you feel like you're in
control even though you are the person
that
holds everything together the
emulsifying agent and this dream would
probably
to me represents bobby could do whatever
he wants
oh look at me i'm going to get naked on
stage and i'm going to come on the floor
oh i'm the best
right and your world is going to take
your
his world is going to take care of you
but why why would your father let
not renee you why would you
allow bobby nurture bobby validate bobby
to be this way
when and i and there's really no
judgment and i don't know
i didn't write the email he didn't oh
okay then i don't know
he was going but congratulations on
family
yeah we don't do compost we don't do
come puddles what do you do
where do you go you know what in her
eyes or her hair
okay dreadlocks i don't believe that
every single time in your eyes or your
hair
every single time that means it always
ends with a blow job or does he like
kind of scoot up and then
[Laughter]
it's an old time yeah yeah what if
you're on top it's over just
you know i am rather tall yeah sure
comparatively
yeah so he walks over to the she's
standing i need her to be standing i
crawl up her like i'm a koala no no no
no no no
no uh-huh tell me does he more
times than not come in your eyes i don't
i don't what i do it this is the truth
this is the truth push it i'll go i'm
about to go i'm about to go
and i lunge off of her wait who's you
lunge
yeah you're never on top whatever i'll
push her off
i push you off yeah right and then i and
i put
i put my hand like this i do my husband
oj yeah yeah we high five right like i'm
about to get it
you know yeah i'm holding it up there
right
right and then i go oh and it goes pink
one little drop and hits and then she
always like a goldfish like catch in
mid-air go up
all right well one thing we need to
redact uh renee when we corrected saying
a friend
to a fan i think you forgot to say just
joking
a friend thank you for being such a such
a big part of this and glad we can make
you happy if you really want to enjoy
your rides
what do you want to play anything you
want
you know people people want to plug just
my podcast what's it called again take
your shoes off that's right
and people have said how they could go
in
i would love for them to see the
comments on yours because they said this
is the greatest guest appearance that
you've ever had
and i think that's not because of me but
i'm glad that we together built an
environment for you
i think we have a good vibe together
yeah i think we have a good chemistry
together
i i i will say something mark my words